[Music]
[Applause]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was you can never have
too many
amy poehler wrote friends
judd apatow wrote ideas
kanye west wrote mirrors with the
blinking word kanye above them
[Applause]
he's honest
miley cyrus is ice-t wrote a spoiled
rich kid
dr phil wrote a complete narcissist
lindsay lohan wrote coming along nicely
when i'm elected the first thing on my
desk will be ted cruz wrote a bill
repealing obamacare
jeb bush wrote an executive order
overturning don't ask don't tell
anthony weiner wrote my penis
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's easier to have fun when jeff
bridges wrote you're surrounded by good
friends
harlan williams wrote you're not
self-conscious
bruce jenner wrote your face looks like
you're permanently riding a six flags
roller coaster
[Applause]
[Music]
now that tim tebow's been cut from the
patriots he should
terry bradshaw wrote try to improve his
throwing mechanics
steve young wrote stay in shape in case
another team calls
jesus christ wrote start taking my hints
and retire from football
that's right jesus christ
wrote me back
[Applause]
and supplied that photo yeah
and
you i guess you wouldn't be surprised
beautiful handwriting yeah beautiful
perfect gorgeous gorgeous but terrible
speller
[Laughter]
he worked on penmanship
our music here's your next one of these
things we're doing our music brings
people
one direction wrote joy
mumford and sons wrote together
jonas brothers wrote conan thanks for
thinking of us but we're plumbers now
oh
i bet it's so cute when they all pile
out of the van
if i could speak
if i could speak to one dead person it
would be gwyneth paltrow wrote jane
austen
jamie foxx wrote martin luther king
wilford brimley wrote me
if i win i'll be the first president to
hillary clinton wrote be a woman
marco rubio wrote b of hispanic descent
chris christie wrote have to pay for two
seats on air force one
when my time comes i want to be
george rr martin wrote buried at sea
colin farrell wrote buried in ireland
joan rivers wrote re-melted into squeaky
toys for my dogs
that would be nice
enjoy her yeah and finally even at my
age i'm still able to jimmy carter wrote
mediate
nancy pelosi wrote legislate
stephen tyler wrote menstruate
well
they all really wrote back
even jesus christ